[Music]
on sunday for the first time in well
over 30 years something interesting
happened during a jets game the
fascinating spectacle didn't take place
on the field of play but on the
sidelines where tampa bay buccaneers
wide receiver antonio brown decided to
quit in the middle of the third quarter
he took off his shoulder pads ripped off
his shirt
pranced off the field while his team was
still playing
and at that point they actually were
losing to the jets and you could almost
excuse this behavior if the sheer
shame of losing to the jets is what
drove him off the field it would at
least be understandable but that doesn't
appear to be the motivating factor
now there are conflicting reports about
what led to his leaving
the field brown's camp claims that the
coach told him to go into the game but
brown refused because he had an ankle
injury and couldn't play and then the
coach cut him on the spot that's what
they're saying
the coach disputes that version of
events it's important to note here that
brown is a liar he's a horrible teammate
on literally every team he's ever played
on and he has a history of quitting on
his on his teams all of his teams he's
quit on all of them so there's no reason
to believe his version also here's how
it looked as he left the field watch
very odd situation antonio brown boiled
over very upset on the sideline took off
his shoulder pads mike evans oj howard
trying to convince him to keep them on
obviously they were unable to do so he
tossed his shoulder pads tripped off his
shirt and glove threw those into the
crowd then ran across the field while
the teams were still on the field giving
the crowd a peace out sign i'll let you
know when we hear something official on
his status
you know you don't normally expect a guy
with a crippling leg injury to dance and
do jumping jacks as he's leaving the
field
so so no i think he simply quit on his
team in the middle of the game that much
is obvious
the bucks did go on to win by four
points although morally speaking beating
the jets by four points is equivalent to
losing by 10 to a real nfl team but in
any case the head coach of the bucks
announced in the post game press
conference that brown was no longer on
the team meanwhile brown took a private
jet back to his house in the middle of
the game
and when he got back to his house he
released a rap song
now i know you may be worried that i'll
play the song for you but you should
know that i would never waste your time
like that just kidding of course i will
here it is
[Music]
well there's no question that um the man
is a poet
maybe there's a little question mostly
because nobody knows what he was saying
there it sounds like he was rapping with
ten jolly ranchers in his mouth but
artistry aside as an athlete brown's
career is finished as it should be he's
an egomaniac he's a crybaby he's a
quitter
he abandoned his team in the middle of a
game and that's the cardinal sin in
sports to quit
or it used to be
but that was before the era of simone
biles when quitting athletes are now
viewed as heroes or at least as victims
who deserve our unending sympathy
and so that quickly became the narrative
in this case also
the ap published a piece uh with this
headline about antonio brown says
antonio brown's mental health is no joke
internet commenters were chastised for
daring to make jokes about the whole
situation quote uh from the writer rob
maddie he scolds us quote brown's mental
health is no joke to be trivialized by a
meme
yeah i mean you heard his rap song this
is a tortured artist we're dealing with
let us not trivialize him
it's not as though he's trivialized
himself right
maddie argued that even if brown is out
of the league forever now he should
still quote get the benefit of various
mental health services the nfl offers
players and team personnel
the other sports other sports writers
chimed in ross tucker said on twitter i
expressed significant concern about
antonio brown's mental health over two
years ago
the man needs help
and then writer bakari sellers tweeted
antonio brown is unstable and needs
mental health treatment the league
doesn't care as long as he runs routes
and catches passes without immediate
help and no football bad things could
happen
someone needs to wrap their arms around
him
now
this again is a grown man we're talking
about
someone needs to wrap their arms around
him
the author malcolm gladwell echoed these
concerns he says i'm stunned by the lack
of sympathy for antonio brown he's
clearly struggling
is this how we treat people who are
going through difficult times
struggling
the poor deer
the poor multi-millionaire athlete
how dare we be so callous to a person
suffering through such a difficult time
you know i just finished reading a book
about the donner party which of course
is the group of 19th century pioneers
who got stuck in the mountains on the
way to california and half of them
starved or froze to death and then their
corpses were eaten by the other half
and needless to say
their whole experience was kind of a
bummer but it pales in comparison to the
plight of a tampa bay buccaneers wide
receiver
i mean no soul has ever suffered so much
as him
on monday afternoon the media asked
brown's former head coach about the
incident
and the questioning mostly revolved
around this this issue of poor antonio's
mental health
listen you've been someone that's
expressed genuine care and concern for
antonio how tough was it for you to see
what happened yesterday and to make that
call
yeah it's very hard and i i i wish him
well i hope
um if he needs help get some and
but um yeah i
it's very hard because i do care about
him
and um was there any type of
conversation with him before you made
that decision post game and was there
any sort of mental health evaluation
performed on him before he left the
stadium
yeah i have no idea
mental health evaluation performed on
him before he left the stadium
it's an nfl team it's not arkham asylum
how would that work exactly
meanwhile back on social media thousands
of random people who also apparently
happen to be expert neurologists all
decided that antonio brown must have cte
which is the brain condition brought on
by repeated blows to the head
it's been declared over and over again
that brown
isn't at fault for any of his actions
he got hit in the head one too many
times and somehow though nobody can
really explain how that caused him to
act like an enormous jerk
now the problem with this diagnosis of
course is that the people making it are
utterly and completely full of crap
cte is still quite mysterious we don't
know for sure how it relates to football
injuries or if it does
and even if it does we don't know how it
would cause people to act in certain
ways or if it does
in other words cte is an excuse for
antonio brown a rationalization
with no evidentiary basis
and which ignores the fact that brown
has been a selfish jerk for his entire
career it's not the it's not the
compounded result of 10 years worth of
concussive episodes he's always been
like this
so that is again an excuse
and the same can be said about the whole
mental health angle in general
you see all of this is part of the
general effort by so many in our culture
to remove agency from the individual
to turn everybody into victims into
patients into sufferers
none of us choose to act in in one way
or another way
rather the actions occur
the choices are made
and we are the victims of the results if
they don't go our way
it's like we're all constantly pleading
insanity for ourselves and one another
in the court of public opinion
don't blame anybody for anything
all bad choices are the fruits of mental
health problems
and blaming someone for a mental health
problem is like blaming them for
arthritis
that's the attitude anyway and it's
totally ridiculous
there are crazy people in this world who
cannot control themselves
who shouldn't be held morally
responsible for their actions but those
people aren't playing in the nfl
they're sitting on park benches arguing
with squirrels
you know those kinds of people when you
meet them they aren't they aren't
mentally with it they aren't competent
they can't care at all for themselves
that's not the case for antonio brown
it's not the case for most of the garden
variety jerks and a-holes who get by on
the mental health excuse these days
for them the problem is not mental
deficiencies but deficiencies of
see we used to talk about and
acknowledge things like character and
virtue
before we decided that all of the
jackasses and schmucks in the world are
actually mental patients
and in antonio brown's case it's not
difficult to pinpoint where his trouble
really began
it begins with this he's a pampered
coddled superstar athlete
and so at the age of 33 he's been a
pampered coddled superstar athlete for
most of his life going back to high
school and that means that he almost
always gets his way
it means people bend over backwards to
accommodate him and satiate him
it means they make excuses for him just
like they're doing right now they give
him more chances than he deserves just
like they're doing right now uh you know
my dad used to tell me that it's good to
get rejected sometimes it's good to fail
because it builds character
and you have to learn how to deal with
not getting what you want
but there are some people who have never
had to learn that lesson
and they end up morally stunted as a
result it's called being entitled it's
not that complicated
most people in our culture today suffer
from
this entitlement disease to one degree
or another a guy like antonio brown has
it terminally
except it's not really a disease because
it's developed as a result of his own
choices his own moral habits
again it's not complicated he's not a
victim
and the more he's treated like one the
worse the problem gets
and that's why antonio brown and also of
course his army of enablers are all
today canceled
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends